hello I wanna like sitting around a fire
with this guy whiskey seriously and just
listen to Hamburg history time I've be
done you'd be wasted
[Music]
whether problem-solving in bone Appetit
test kitchen or crabbing in the Alaskan
wilderness
Brad Leone's blooper filled fish out of
water culinary explorations are
extremely lovable so in the spirit of
broadening our horizons I invited the
host of it's alive to spend an afternoon
at Burger scholar George Moses house to
learn about the history of three classic
regional burger styles Brad the second
welcome to the prank give thanks for
having me I'm so excited to introduce
you to my man George Motz George how are
you gonna be steak yeah whenever I come
here I find out about the regionality of
burgers and I didn't even know that that
even existed oh good let's learn I like
a little education with my food and
they're like yes sir a little history of
it you can deeply do you could seriously
ask him about anything burger he's in
he'll have an answer all right that's
fun no sir she asked no I don't have a
question right now my job is to protect
the American hamburger I really feel
like I like it you know I'm a bit of a
planner and a defender important job
poor guy really I think very seriously
we're about to go in a regional
adventure the three burgers today are
gonna be the Jersey burger the Barack
which is from Kansas Nebraska and the
bean burger from San Antonio let's get
started you're from Jersey yes sir New
Jersey has a lot of diners yes there is
a lot and a lot of these diners
especially the hamburger of diners the
small counters they do make sliders they
still make traditional American sliders
the sliders based on method all right I
like that not on size not just three
little stupid meatballs on a bad brioche
bun right that's a mini perhaps
otherwise me totally crazy burger is not
a slider see why here protecting like
the heritage is very thick mini burgers
never taste gas my grabber cheese why do
they call it a cider they would take a
like a porcelain plate they put the
burger on top of that and they would
literally slide it down the counter and
that's how it became no it's a slider
slider come give me a sign came down the
counter yeah look I wanna like sitting
around a fire with this guy seriously
and just listen to hamburg mister the
time I would be done you'd be wasting
this is a little bigger a slider would
be like it outs in half this is a three
ounce slider why I'm put some onions in
there so normally we'd do it takes them
thin slice today onion
oh yeah uh-huh steam them out right on
that it's great in there cuz they'll
swim it based in an onion juice because
the most important part is just actually
press it there so we're gonna make this
mash you up yep yes yeah that'll sell
anymore no sold out sold out I'll get
you 110 grand email me show the good old
Taylor pork roll jersey knit up Taylor
hammer teleportal yes Taylor ham yeah
what is where I come from no one would
ever call it pork roll okay that's like
you get closer down there and Philly
folks and stuff go that's nice that's
perfect but that's why would you do that
we didn't it would cup up like a
pepperoni American cheese see that's why
I would have maybe I think that is very
what everyone would do yeah in New
Jersey I just I'm not a huge American
cheese no well like it's the undisputed
king of cheeses but for hiss me off
forever you know Americans cheese I
didn't have a say in this
guess what it was invented by a Canadian
of course it was every time you actually
have the bun is on top of the you know
nearly finished products is actually as
they're steaming oh right on the counter
hand that's gonna yeah so a friend of
mine New Jersey rich Belfer
says he invented this I'm just have you
guys watch me no no no let's let's put
this for you guys every day good I
already had for you today
oh that's it mmm really well no it's
great the mixture I wouldn't and I like
that it's not a big thing meat I got a
lot no three quarter pound hamburger
patty I'd rather to then one big one
this is like throwing a piece of spam
yeah in your burger very similar it's
really good yeah it doesn't even need
anything no grease is a condom huh yeah
I can't find a great diner in New York
is that they're all in Jersey for some
reason
yeah I don't know it was back I guess I
guess we need someone we need a diner
history guy George's cousin people from
New Jersey hold on to tradition more
than any place else in the truck
generation they loved her to China have
it so because of that diners cannot go
away
people need those things to basically
subsist and the whole lingo of it's
pretty rad lingo yeah well Jersey people
have their own lingo period this is a
game I want to call how Jersey are you
Oh God oh he's got cars yeah oh my god
they're burger show cards question one
I'm ready all right
what is the boss the musician Bruce
Springsteen correct but is Bon Jovi you
said the boss we didn't say Bon Jovi win
say you know okay we even mentioned that
in the same breath my mom she's probably
in the stands you know jumping around
and [ __ ] but Bon Jovi's not really my
thing
alright the next question what is a
Benny Benny yeah that's someone who that
would be like if you went to the Jersey
Shore
what is djibouti mean jumuchi I don't
know like use my job I'm not sure
Djibouti I guys just like someone who's
like like lazy and I cut see I'm kind of
in the way like you being a Jew puch get
out of the way I [ __ ] love that
there's a lot of guys in my kitchen what
is a gabagool
[Music]
we're going to Kansas now Kansas
Nebraska all right original specialty
that you actually can't really buy in
restaurants at all this is something you
can really only buy or you can actually
find out like a church function a church
function yeah all right it's old school
this is an old school thing about beef
right looking garlic what the hell is
going on here yeah we ditch the griddle
no griddle no patty Martin's got
we still got our Canadian cheese and we
got some dough the pizza this is gone
yeah so fermenter we're actually making
it we're making something that actually
predates the American hamburger by a few
decades the Barack Barack Barack where
is this from
it all started in 18th century Russia
with German farmers settled along the
banks of the Volga River these Volga
Germans adapted a Russian pierogi create
the Barack a dough filled pocket filled
with beef onions and cabbage that farm
hands could stuff into their pockets
variations on this handheld snack can be
found all around the world from the
Cornish pasty to the empanada even the
hot pocket as the political climate
shifted in Russia volga germans
eventually migrated to the United States
spread in the Barack to the Great Plains
where it became a regional icon this is
just very stretchy down that's all it is
cool let's notice piece of dough simply
square some stuff off here okay yeah a
little fold default
yeah totally fold you gets baked and
that's it easy magic here this there it
is calzone also in the calzone family
kyani it's a burger this is its I think
it's not a burger it's X but it's in the
burger family for sure oh yeah that's
the stuff huh yeah oh thank you sir see
that perfect bite right there I'm not
hating on this no that's pretty damn
good 25 of those hmm the definition of a
burger to me right now it's starting to
get like a little little skewed you know
you're like it's like to me that's a
burger but it's also a dumpling by
definition at Burger has to be ground
beef cooked some house served on bread
and that's it I agree yeah I'm into that
so everything that we've learned so far
yes and you've had guests at your house
yeah would you make them the beer Akbar
I would buy just I don't think I'd call
it a burger I definitely make list you
know I wouldn't call it a burger either
it's like it it's like a distant weird
cousin of the burger in the family but
kind of not really in the family but
it's fun no he gets it
stories come out it's fair right at
Thanksgiving Texas is very well
represented in my book hamburger America
because there's so much hamburger
activity going on in Texas and then you
go to San Antonio and there's the hyper
regional bean burger you can't beat that
flattop Doha when it comes to making a
burger it really is well actually
cooking in its own fat yeah that's
really the beauty of this thing you know
we have to put Fritos off right on the
butter is on the bottom so Texas huh now
the most important part refried beans I
love the idea of good refried mean I
beat you have to make your own reframing
oh yeah I use lard for sure so good this
is straight-up cheese they may put it on
top of this here if I was at home I'd be
like audible we're putting that on the
chips that's actually yeah keeping it
you know together and summer audience on
top sorry I like crunch to go with your
french well yeah that's not messy and
that's that messy no it's not
he left San Antonio good luck try to eat
this thing go do it mmm
[Music]
that's like some stoner burger right
there those chips
yeah onions drive it home yeah it's true
yeah they driving home from brings any
texture to right yeah it's it gets good
combo but the beef fat drips onto the
peas
yeah Fritos it's Jimmy songs I'm oh yeah
but in like the best way pretty damn
good
what would you say was your favorite of
all the three oh I think I'm gonna go
with it the Taylor ham burger I'm going
with the Jersey to the first one yeah I
was I was starving but chasey is
fragrant yeah
like it had the onion that like steamed
out and got crispy the saltiness of the
pork but not really favorite deviate
from the simple answer but I would
probably eat more of the weird Nebraska
yeah the beer of Iraq yeah yeah
surprisingly us
I'd probably a couple of those problem
yeah really getting into this regional
or what you call it when it's just to a
sacred regional hyper region or regional
that's why ice why I love coming here
George thanks for having yes awesome
thanks Brad
now I'm craving burgers yeah fun yeah
but there should be a nice Jersey to
just still more to do I mean there's so
much more out there hey that's why I job
security
[Music]
you
[Music]
what's up everybody it's having Kyle out
of the burger show make sure you turn on
your notifications smash that like
button smash that subscribe button and
thank you for watching